If DNA is information, it requires
intelligence. That's basic like logical
argument like it provokes thought. Yeah.
Okay. But wouldn't you say there is
evidence to God? What's stopping you
from accepting it? Heterosexual couple
having children. It is well better. It's
much better for the children. Yes, it
is. There's studies that show it. It's
not even me. It's not even me. It's not
even me. Yeah. Yeah. I'm not It's nice
talking to you.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a saddak for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation,
you will in be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can. When
did you paint your face? Few hours ago.
Few hours. Okay. You drew specific
patterns on purpose. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So, it's not it's not random. Well, it's
from a video game. That's why the
square. Uh what's it called? What's that
game called? Minecraft. Minecraft.
Minecraft. We'll get there in a minute.
Minecraft. Okay. So,
are you a Muslim? No. No. My my best
friend back home. Listen. What happened
to your face? Who done it? Was it you?
This is how I look normal, mate. Really?
You look handsome, mate. You look
handsome, man. You know, you know what
it is? He's extra handsome. So, he had
to cover himself so he doesn't get
attention from the girls. Yeah, that's
it. But you know what? If you become a
Muslim, if you get a Muslim, you can
become You can have four wives. Yeah, I
can have four wives. You can have four
wives. You look after them. You treat
them well. Yeah. Okay. No side chick
thing going on. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So,
what's stopping you from accepting
Islam? Oh, I still believe in God. I
respect I respect his teachings and like
the All right. Let's talk Let's talk
about Let's talk. I've got I've got a
fast argument for you. Okay. Are you
ready for it? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Right
now, you painted your face. When did you
paint your face? A few hours ago. Few
hours ago. Okay. If I'm not mistaken,
you drew specific patterns on purpose.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, it's not it's not
random. No, it's not random. Okay.
Right. No problem. So, this is very
interesting. Yeah. So, you picked you
looked at your eyes and said, "Should I
make them circle, triangle, or square?"
Well, it's from a video game. That's why
the square. Good. So, um uh what's it
called? What's that game called?
Minecraft. Minecraft. It's up there in a
minute. Minecraft. Okay. So, you looked
at Minecraft. You actually stole the
design from them. Yeah, I did. Okay.
Good. Check this out. Yeah. So, so I'm
sure you'd have maybe come up with
something similar, but you looked at
Minecraft and designed somebody that
designed that game, made it, you copied
it and took it on board. Yeah. Guess who
else does that? For example, do you know
um there's a specific bird? I forgot the
name of the bird. It's got like specific
beak. Yeah. So, when they were making
trains, you know, the bullet train.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've seen that. Yeah.
Okay. You've seen it. Okay. So,
basically what happened is human beings
they learn from God. How? Because
there's design out there. Now the design
what they used to do with the trains was
it wasn't shaped in that way and what
they would do is when they go through
the tunnel there will be a sonic boom.
So in order to prevent that you know
very well that the bird they looked at
the bird the beak of the bird and they
learn from it. So it's a similar thing
cuz you're looking at Minecraft and
you've adopted the style. Now the
question I want to ask is this would you
accept that if there is
information requires intelligence? Yeah.
Okay. Would you accept that we are
composed of DNA? Yeah. And the DNA is a
a a gene that has three billion letters.
Yes. Okay. So these genes are the same
throughout your body. The only
difference is that it's how it lights up
that makes your heart the way it looks.
The eyes. Okay. So would you not accept
that if DNA is information? It requires
intelligence.
I believe it's random. I think No.
What's randomness? Like if you're a man
of science, you can't even believe in
randomness. Like I think you can. I mean
everything's random. It's a chance. A
random chance. Do you have a coin? Uh I
don't have a coin. Okay. If I had a coin
now and if I flipped it, would we say
what's the chance of being heads or
tails?
Is it a chance? There is chance. No,
it's not. Let me tell you why. What's
your name, by the way? Hish. Hey, my
name's Ali. Nice to meet you, man. I
love you, man. Okay. Now, if we if we
know all the factors when we flip that
coin, the power I flip you on, the
weather, and all other dynamics, the
gravitational force, we would know the
outcome every single time. The reason we
call it chance is because we don't know
all the factors. However, in science,
there is no such thing as chance. So
there's everything that's cause and
effect. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? So what it means is that for
example, when I pour the water, we can't
say it's going to splatter around. No,
it doesn't. If we knew all the factors
when that water spills, we will know
exactly where it will go. So we don't
actually, this is called hard
determinism. Yeah. So what that means is
that everything is kind of
predetermined. So what I'm saying is the
following that we know from nothing,
nothing comes. We know that we are
composed of DNA and DNA requires
information. Yeah. Yeah. So therefore it
requires that if DNA is information it
requires intelligence. That's basic like
logical argument.
Just the way you have a pattern. Look
you've got a pattern on your face. Yeah.
Yeah. I see. I see. I see. I see your
approach. Just thought provoking like it
provokes thought. Yeah. Okay. But
wouldn't you say there is evidence to
God? What's stopping you from accepting
it? I just think evolution is all
random. I just don't Okay. But
evolution. Look, let me talk about
evolution. I think just I I just don't
see
I I still want to be restricted in life.
No, you're not. I'm Muslim. I'm not
religious. Yeah. Now, let me put it like
this. Yeah. Of course, I'm not allowed
to eat pork. I'm not allowed to drink
alcohol. I'm not have sex outside of
marriage. Yeah. But the thing is that
what we're saying is that you're you
also follow some some sort of a
religion. You can't come and tell me
you're absolutely free. You cannot come
and tell me that you painting your face
did not have an influence on Minecraft.
We are all influenced by something one
shape or another. So your way of life is
a bit different to mine but however you
follow certain protocols as well without
subconsciously not consciously knowing.
Now when you talk about evolution I
don't know if you Dennis noble so Dennis
noble is challenging the whole theory of
not totally but evolution cuz why is
what they did is they found some new new
recent um discoveries which they you
know they call it um uh natural
selection. Yes. Okay. Random mutation.
Yeah. Okay. Now they finding it's not
random it's actually targeting mutation.
What that means is that when we look at
the nucleus of the cell and around the
cell membrane, there is these new things
that Dennis Norman discovered called
tubulants. So they like tubes that have
they carry information to the nucleus.
Meaning that for example your today you
don't have a jacket. Yeah. Now if we
live in a very cold environment, your
body is going to start sending that
information to the nucleus and it's
going to start causing you to argue.
Let's say grow more hair. So what we see
is that's not random. There's an
information that's happening in your
nucleus. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? So, what we're saying is that it is
impossible that on a micro level to a
macro level, we have order. We have the
atoms. So, how is it that this all
spontaneously came to be when I would
look at your face and be like, I know
someone painted that. If I came and
said, you know what, I believe chance
you woke up today like this. Would you
not call me crazy?
Yeah. No, I should. You know what I'm
saying? So, I think you're an
intelligent man. Yeah. You're handsome.
Thank you. Become a Muslim and get two
wives. Come on. But you need to treat
them right. Yeah. Okay. What's stopping
you from like would you tell me what
evidence do you do you require more to
believe in God? Cuz right now I feel
like you're in those steps where you're
like, "Okay, it's thought provoking. I
want to think about it." Um I just um
you know just
point homosexuality. Okay. No problem.
Okay. Homosexuality. So you're saying
that that is stopping you from believing
in God? Yeah. Exactly. I don't in my
idea of a god that would be okay. Love's
love. Okay. No. Okay. If you do you
believe love is love, do you believe
love is love? Yeah. Okay. Okay. Then we
have to be fair and apply that to all
categories. Are you okay with a a
brother and sister having sex? I think
that's different. I don't think you can
call it the same thing. But love is
love. They can come and say love is
love.
For example, I don't think it's the same
thing. I think it's dangerous comparing
the two things. But I say the same thing
with homosexuality. What I say is this
though, you can be a Muslim and a
homosexual. By the way, Islam does not
say you acting on that act takes you out
the fold of Islam. There are there are
Muslims who are gay, but that doesn't
the main credal thing is that to believe
in one God and try to abide by his
legislation. Now, what we see is the
following. To be consistent, we need to
apply it all places and all that. Like
for example, a a a mother and his
22year-old son should have sex.
But why how is that the same? Because
let me tell you how a man and a man and
a woman and a woman says this is love.
Even though for example somebody will
come and say a man to be penetrating
another man's rectum is actually there's
many problems with it etc. Yeah. Um be
diseases and all that kind of stuff.
Let's put that to a side. I don't think
diseases I mean you can't be saying
that. That's that's a stereotype. That's
wrong. Is there no there's no diseases?
No no that's very deeply rooted in
stereotypes. That's very wrong. No, no,
I know. But it's like for example, do
you not accept that for example a man
where he defecates from and a man
inserting his penis into that place? Um,
will there not be sexual diseases? There
is like, you know, there was a whole
monkey. That's not how it started. No,
I'm not saying how it started. I'm
saying that for example, monkey pox, it
was predominantly through homosexual
men. I'm not I'm not saying all the
time. I'm just saying for example, if a
a brother and sister straight people
have sexual disease, of course, that's
why in Islam we even like we believe
that there should be no sex outside of
marriage. So it's not just for the
homosexuals, it's for anybody. So what
we're saying is this a a a mother who's
55y old and his her son which is 27
years old there should be nothing wrong
with them having sex because love is
love if we use the same category. So
we're saying we have to be consistent or
we can't pick and choose. Even like
pedophilia, some people are coming out
and saying, "Oh, they have been they've
been born like this." I think it's
dangerous to put all that in the same
group. That's not the same thing. But
being consistent, how could you
differentiate? So how's a man and a man
loving each other different to a man and
a woman loving each other? No, no. I'm
saying if if how is that how is that
different? Let's suppose it's the same.
I'm going with your argument. A man and
a woman loving each other and a man and
a man loving each other the same. No
problem. A a a brother and sister loving
each other. A petal who says, "I have
love towards You've already made a
difference. You're saying a man and a
woman is normal. No, no. I'm saying
that's allowed. No, I'm saying let's
suppose all of them are normal. No, but
you're saying by saying that one of them
is allowed, you got to apply that to
everything. You've already made
exceptions. No, no. I'm applying a man
and a woman, but you wouldn't let a
mother and son. You have made an
exception. No, I'm not. I'm saying let's
allow it. You're saying let's allow. No,
no, but it's not allowed, is it? No, no,
no. I'm saying it's not allowed. Is it
allowed? In Islam, it's not allowed.
Exactly. Inadeception. No. In Islam, a a
a man and a woman having sex outside of
marriage is not allowed. A man and a man
having a sex not allowed. A woman and a
woman have family. Is that allowed? What
family? Mother and son. No, that's not
allowed. So, exactly. You've made an
exception. No, I've said no. I've said
all of them are haram. You're saying one
thing. No, you're saying man and woman
is fine. No, no, no. I'm saying all of
them are haram except in marriage. In
marriage, you're saying man and woman is
fine. Yeah, exactly. And that's an
exception. Of course, I'm making an
exception, but I'm saying if I play them
as advocate and go to I'm saying
anything that's not within a family or
different age groups, that's fine. Okay,
good. So, I'm saying that's fine. I'm
saying let's go with it. I'm on your
boat. I'm saying okay, let's go with it.
So my exceptions are not okay. Your
exceptions are okay. That's what that's
what they're getting at here. Hear me
out. Hear me out. I'm saying a man and a
woman getting married in marriage is
fine. Anything outside that be
homosexuality, whatever, whatever is not
is not allowed in Islamic. But but to
your worldview, you said a man and a man
loving each other is fine. A woman and a
woman loving is fine. I said why are you
excluding for example a brother and
sister having sex? Why are you allowing
a man and a woman? You're excluding
everything else. You allow man because
because we believe that is the most
perfect way. It's a nuclear family. It
is more healthy. For example, there's
even studies that show a a a a
homosexual couple. That's not right. No,
no, it's not about right. Studies, don't
blame me. Look, don't shoot the
messenger. There are studies. There are
studies that shows they are more. They
are more likely to infect sexual
diseases. Homosexual parents are
absolutely fine. Diseases are not more
likely. That is such an outdated
stereotype. Diseases is another thing.
But that's an outdated. You can't say
that point when it's such an outdated
stereotype. That's fine. So what I'm
saying is recent studies show that
homosexual couples, couples who have
children, they have more mental issues.
They are more excluded. Okay, they have
this is studies, not me. Don't take my
word. Recent studies that show that a
homosexual couple, be it a man and a man
or a woman or woman. I know people with
straight varants who are look at
studies. No, of course. I'm not I'm not
saying you can't you can't I'm not
saying one thing's bad, one thing. No,
no, no. What I'm saying is in general a
a heterosexual couple having children,
it is well better. It's much better for
the children. Yes, it is. There's
studies that show it. It's not even me.
It's not even me. It's not even done.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm not It's nice talking to
you. But but but we have to be
consistent as well. Let's be consistent.
Yeah. That's the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said, "Whoever builds a
masid for the sake of Allah subhanaa
tala, Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jenna." On that day where Allah
subhana t tells us that our books will
be given and every little atom weight of
good deed will be there and imagine you
see a mountain and you're like what a
lucky person which righteous person and
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do you allowed people to pray
you built a masid I never had the money
to build a masjid oh Allah you helped
you gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you've built it
donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra rewards.
[Music]